having to do with the coronavirus a
tremendous amount and a lot of them were
covered and we know them from the media
they've all got very interesting and
very different stories to tell and I
felt what I do is I'd go around the room
it's an honor to have them at the White
House and they really are they're very
brave some were right at the edge they
thought it was over there's a rough a
rough plague I called it the plague I
call it the scourge I call it whatever
you want to call it it's rough it's bad
and a woman that I've really found
fascinating and she's from a state
that's a great state and a city that's
been hit very hard really very very hard
Detroit
highly respected she's a political
person she doesn't happen to be a
Republican and that's okay when things
aren't going good and you get a little
help from a Republican we'll take that
too but your story was just a fit just a
fantastic story and we're going to go
around the room each of you this man was
an NFL football player for ten years a
friend of Tom Brady and he was hit hard
and you do you were so strong when you
got hit by that that little yeah you are
not you're saying you were not you
didn't feel too powerful so if we could
we'll go around the room and if we could
start with you representative and
congratulations it's an incredible story
thank you
honor to be here and it's such an honor
to be here amongst all of you survivors
I just can't say how wonderful it is to
see your face and thank you for
everything that you have done I did not
know that saying thank you had about a
political line I didn't know that I
thought just saying thank you man thank
you and I do I sincerely appreciate that
because had you not brought this to the
forefront of the the HQ of being able to
put this out here I wouldn't be here
today to even have this conversation
with you and to be able to talk about
the needs of Detroit and talk about the
people who really need this and they
need help and you're here to address
that and I sincerely appreciate that
from the both of you from the bottom of
my heart from the people of my city
where you were so incredible as a
representative both in terms of how you
got better and what you went through
and your husband sounds like a great
gentleman he went down there and he took
care of things right he took care of
that that means he loves you because
some husbands would say yeah that's my
father he what he will do whatever he
has to do right so that's when I was
late in the evening you did that and we
had the drugstore stocked with the with
the medicine and that's fantastic what
didn't you why don't you say what got
you to go late in the night to the drug
sir
what got me to go late at night we were
trying to do everything we could
she's real sick so we kind of kind of
not panic and I she's making she's
making phone calls and once we got the
doctor to put in the script no guys no
[ __ ] that's when we I wouldn't get it
around that guy's the wallet is amazing
world-renowned doctor in the state of
Michigan in a doctor from a hospital or
a local doctor he's a doctor at local
doctor but he is in charge of the AMA in
Michigan and he has nine urgent care
clinics and he has been on Fox with me
as well but doctor Sawalha is amazing
and he has taken care of my family as
well and I've lost several family
members to Kovac all all in one
household my cousin Shura father was a
was in ICU she lost her husband he was
turned away from numerous hospital as
was she over four times and within six
hours she lost her father-in-law who was
turned away numerous times her whole
family had to be tested which are seven
family members and those family I've
those seven family members she's had
three of those tested positive and that
is her children thanks to doctor Sawalha
and what you have done they're doing
great but it can't be just so they took
the hydroxy then yes they did it but it
can't be just based on my name and your
name it needs to be something that's
readily available to everyone in the
city of Detroit well I hear that the
governor has gone all out for it from
being totally opposed to it now she's
all out for it so that's what I'm
hearing
so that's a good thing I think it's a
good thing so you might have said when
you started that walk or run what the
hell do I have to lose right you know my
expression what do I have to lose she
was a veg I just ate congratulations
it's an incredible story and I like
Democrats I especially like this
Democrat though for just two reason you
have a beautiful you have a beautiful
presence and you're a beautiful couple
and thank you for coming
I have a feeling she's gonna go very
much up she's a good representative
right now but I have a feeling
politically do you have any further
political ambitions you think I actually
did not even aspire to be a state
representative to be perfectly honest so
I don't know I may have to cross party
lines I may have to work with her and
cross party lines thank you very much
great honor to have me of please tell us
your story my story is we were on the
diamond princess or ground zero and and
I didn't get the virus there although I
tested positive there didn't learn about
it till later we were flung back thanks
to you we flung back by the state
department to first nobody would take
the diamond princess yeah no would take
it nobody wanted it it was like it was
you know they call it a ghost ship not
good so we took it we were stuck there
it was like we were on a peak of
floating petri dish we're watching the
bodies get off daily off into ambulances
taken out one by one a total of 750 of
us over time were taken out we we were
more than double the amount of outbreaks
if you added everyone in the world at
the time other than China and China
wasn't giving us any information if you
added all that up we doubled the amount
of people who had the virus people right
ultimately on the ship the ship was 11
people have died from the plane right
back on the 747 military plane I woke up
with a high fever over 103 they put me
in a quarantine area next to about eight
other people
we landed in Sacramento at Travis Air
Force Base and then they saw me and so I
had a condition of pre condition of
guillain-barré syndrome 67 years old you
didn't have a pre condition
three condition so they blew me they had
three of us in quarantine and then my
wife and two others who never who didn't
have the virus and my wife never got the
virus she should be the one study right
now
I was flown together no six foot thing
no nothing you went together and you
didn't catch it
Wow they just started taking yesterday
Providence Health and services on the
west coast to start to do a study before
there's an immunity without knowing it
we'll find out yeah so you know it's
amazing to be together like that and
they're like a charlie that we had two
friends so we were going back and forth
in each of our cabins they got exposed
they got the virus we were stuck on it
there good great they came out great we
were stuck on a bus for six and a half
hours with people with the virus on the
plane people at the virus she sat next
to a husband of a couple who got married
on the Potomac Princess they were in
their 40s and the wife was next to me in
the bio in the in the special
quarantined area on the plane
the husband was next to her coughing
away when we ended up
[Music]
get over my head because we were so cold
and the smell from the toilets the two
portable toilets on me was so bad and
that was when I on a plane that was on
the cargo plane that you guys the bus
well the bus was first so that was a
very long process getting off so that
was no pleasure in there no these people
right it's amazing yeah our friend from
st. George he did not have it on the
boat but tested four days later at Fort
Travis so he either got it on the plane
or on the bus brought you to YouTube you
think it brought you together closer it
brings you together does that make any
sense yeah five weeks because I was in
the bio containment area in Omaha and
then to a lower level of delivery shake
at one point just just the first day on
the plane I had the hundred and three
fever by the time I got to Omaha I was
okay I still had symptoms I still had a
cough that stayed with me for about two
and a half weeks I had shortness of
breath for about four or five days was
it noticeable it was no not noticeable
when I was lying in bed but if I got up
and walked around the room if I walked
around the room and talked on the phone
at the same time trying to multitask
that was impossible to do really how
about you you had shortness of breath -
I read right the shortness this
shortening is the shortening of breath
is what really got me afraid because I
do have
even thank you for always mentioning
about Lyme disease this is a big deal
the thank you for always bringing it to
you think you still have Lyme disease
I do I have chronic Lyme disease because
I was never treated in time can that be
can you get rid of it the thing that
people don't talk about it is a brutal
and if you have a certain type of blood
you have no chance
breathing is what scared me the most and
it came I went from zero to a hundred it
was from getting tested that day on
March 31st to trying to do a few things
around the house to just all of a sudden
my breathing became late so you actually
had a hard time breathing oh yeah I was
afraid I was afraid for my life and
until anyone has been in that person's
shoes until you have walked that walk
and sitting there knowing that the
hospitals near you are full the very two
hospitals that are near you that you
have access to mate you cannot get into
do you think in retrospect you were
better staying home I was there
you know those hospices Dave can be
crowded and I and I didn't know what my
status was so can you imagine you don't
know what your status is and if you
could get into the hospital and then the
way I was filling up with fluid my lungs
my breathing being labored I felt if I
didn't get that medication it was either
the medication or done so you thought
you were gonna die I honestly thought I
was going to die and like I tell people
I'm telling my story I'm telling my
truth I'm not telling anyone else's
story I'm not telling anyone else what
to do I'm telling my story and my
and this is how I feel and these are my
words well I'm not gonna speak for it
but I don't see you're voting for sleepy
Joe but she boasts the sleepy Joe I'd be
surprised okay anyway incredible story
it's such a great story thank you but
your wife I think we're gonna we're
gonna keep you away from round we'll
keep her around what's in the veins
great great stories thank you both
further please okay yeah so I mean I
consider myself a relatively healthy
individual probably get sick once every
couple years you know and to think that
I had something like this was very kind
of surprising and I think that to think
that you have a virus after being such a
healthy individual you don't know where
you got it so I travel a lot and I had a
the flu a little bit and so I think my
immune system was compromised while I
was traveling and it could have been
just kind of community transfer so it's
been a just accepting that I had to
think was the very hardest part but then
too for something like that to take me
down for almost eight days of fever and
then three days of red I've never felt
this bad in my most recent recollection
I think today so compared you said you
had the flu a number of times how did
you compare this to the flu never felt
these symptoms before for this long so a
bigger better much worse event yep and I
only took Thailand on the entire time I
took a lot of it I think the most
frustrating part honestly was trying to
get a test I think that going to
numerous places and being turned away by
a sign on the door that says don't come
in here if you have these symptoms I
think that was this was early March so I
think part of the challenge was there
was a lot of people seeing a lot of
different things and kind of knowing
what to believe where to go you kind of
go in circles a lot when did you find
out officially did you have it I think
on March this is probably about seven
seven or eight days into my
I found out so I got the test of entry
and it's kind of interesting there's
like certain keywords that when you say
those at an ER that they automatically
treat you differently and so for me it
was more of like an education for a lot
of my friends and family okay so what
were the words for me it was more of I
have a fever and I had been in San
Francisco those two may sue them make
them treat you better or worse or or did
they treat you like you had the coven
they treated me like I had kovat so they
set me outside of the ER to make sure
that I don't kind of become contagious
and infect other people and I weighed
out for a little bit and then they came
in and they swapped me and stuff like
that so they did kind of take me I lost
seriously and they got got me a test and
got me an influenza test so I think it's
one of those things that each there's a
lot of unknowns there's a lot of
questions as to who to test who not to
test and I think at that time there was
a lot of a lot of people providing
recommendations and some of them are
completely you ever think you were gonna
die the so when I got the news that I
had kovat I think I had anxiety because
there was so much going on and I think
that kind of accelerated my shortness of
breath symptoms and the second day I
kind of felt that you know something was
wrong I need to go in the hospital I
didn't think I was gonna die but I've
never felt this bad before and I think I
needed medical there's worse you would
have been in deep trouble did you have a
problem with your breathing I did I got
a pulse ox meter and just having one of
those and knowing that your oxygen
levels are normal it's like a kind of
confidence builder that you know you're
not going downhill
but it's what was he doing dude mine was
always above 95% you looked okay yeah
but you still felt a shortness of breath
yeah and so when did you get better
probably around day 11 I had
that's a long time a long time but you
get better quickly after the medication
for the Medicaid I think just letting
amazing we can't get people to
officially you know if somebody else
endorsed that medication it would be
great I think you have a lot of
endorsements if we get a lot of done in
theory no by the way we have tremendous
endorsements but if with somebody else
other than President Trump that put it
forward if some other person put it
forward they'd say oh let's go with it
you know what do you have to lose if
you're taking it for 40 years for
malaria which by the way it's an
unbelievable malaria pill unbelievable
lupus pills
unbelievable thank the problem we had is
people Lucas and with I think I heard
Lyme disease - yeah no it's another very
powerful but it's incredible because
there's so many stores like yours it's
not just I actually haven't heard a bad
story you want to know that you know
nobody it is some good ones and bad ones
and you still give it a shot I haven't
heard a bad story so it's it's pretty
amazing actually but that's okay the
word is that you know the people get it
these people don't get it the media but
the people get it anyway well that's it
that's a great source see you feeling
good now yeah you're gonna go conquer
the world as a young handsome guy how
old e 34 that's good you have a great
life ahead of you congratulations
thank you so I've seen this band my my
story is unlike a lot of these people
here my wife is with me we both were in
Colorado came back to Arkansas and on
the following Monday we had our mostly
her flu-like symptoms
I felt a little bit bad fatigue but my
symptoms were not bad I was diagnosed
because I took her to the doctor on
Tuesday and he the doctor had enough
intuition to look at me and could tell
that something
her purse and I was in the room with her
like a very wealthy couple
so I think the scary thing about me
because I he tested me and I was
positive she also was positive but I did
I never had fever I never had
respiratory issues I did have the body
aches the chills
I felt overall bad but in general I
would have gotten up that Monday morning
if she had not been sick even though I
felt that I would have gone to work I
would have continued on my daily routine
in them and now I'm fearful that maybe
what do you do work in sales for a
pharmaceutical company so my fear is
that people are not exhibiting symptoms
but they which was much harder yeah she
was bad but well not as bad as some of
these but definitely with that shortness
of breath which actually came later
which is another thing that's
interesting
yes and the first few days I just had a
really bad headache and fever loafie
100.4 enough to make you feel bad and
the chills in the aches and then that
lasts about five six days and then I
thought I was I was telling people I'm
fine
you know it was just kind of like a bad
flu it's not that big a deal and you
know still in quarantine and everything
but it was the second week that then the
respiratory hit so you you almost felt
you were better than it came back I mean
not released but felt felt strong enough
and
was hit hard I think it was like that
next Wednesday and then the shortness of
breath and the and I also got a pulse ox
which shouldn't make me feel better
but just it came in waves I mean I had
three probably different waves and
tested positive again after a month and
I am negative now but you know it and
ever met we were positive on the
symptoms were that March the not yet
first symptoms were the ninth and I
didn't test negative until five days ago
oh you know I'm great 100% I would say
85 doesn't it the people that we were
with in Colorado every every adult or it
was positive with covin 19 and when we
returned we visited friends they so far
everybody is fine no one's gone into the
hospital and I think they're working
with us doing the things we're doing
we're donating blood when necessary I've
done convalescent plasma as well no it
seems to be very important a lot of
people when they recover they weren't to
donate
because you know your blood is very good
for this right according to every study
we have it's good and the only question
is is it for one year or is it for a
lifetime it could be you know the
measles and things where it's for a
lifetime they say but it's gonna be
interesting we just don't know because
it hasn't been here long enough it could
be for a left well that's a you donated
blood I actually did convalescent plasma
that's good it's good very promising and
you'll be a hundred percent absolutely I
think I'm almost scared to say under
percent because that's because I think I
said that before in I'm I'm good
well that's a great story thank you very
much both it's great it's great that it
worked out so well
has anybody you're okay
you are as good as a failure as good as
you were before this happened yes and I
think you do right I think you better
these are political property just you do
have and I think just because of my
underlying condition I do have the
tiredness that comes in the tiredness
does kick up and it will come out of
nowhere and I just kind of hit I just
kind of
I'm a little surprised they can't do
something with your lime disease
diseases what does dr. ask the White
House doctor um seriously because Lyme
disease can be very very bad it also can
be is it legal for me to allow her to
use the White House doctor you know what
if it's not uncle suffering and
repercussions I don't care the Democrats
might not like because you cannot get
treated in Michigan as a doctors these
fifth for Lyme disease people don't know
about lung disease it's a very bad
something over period of time you can
treat generally it also can kill you
Lyme disease again if you have a certain
type blood you get a lot of disease it's
over
it's literally I think Type O Type O
blood is not too good if you have type O
blood
stay out of the woods right you got it
at home in Detroit but usually it's from
a deer tick right it is a deer so
whether the tick come from well the tick
does not discriminate it will get on
anything so it comes somehow
discriminate well it's like when I hit a
ball into the rough in golf you know
what I say enjoy yourself
I'm not going to Lyme disease is pretty
tough it is it's a bad word I'd like you
to see our doctor before you leave okay
thank you all right I'm gonna just say
because sometimes they do have a very
very powerful antibiotic and you know
let's see we can help you out okay so
this band as you can possibly tell my
look was a great athlete and a great
football player and I I didn't know walk
but he said Tom Brady says hello to you
Tom Brady is a friend of mine and a
great guy and just signed a nice new big
contract right with a team that's
supposed to have a lot of potential
Tampa Bay I figured he picked a team I'm
sure he only picked a team with a lot of
potential and it's gonna be how do you
think Tom Brady's gonna do I think it
dude great coach Aaron's is a guy that I
I have worked with him before with the
Cleveland Browns yeah he's gonna love be
a they'll work great together
so mark spent 10 years in the NFL and I
guess you played with Tom Brady at
Michigan right yep sir did you notice
did you could you see at Michigan cuz he
was picked a little bit late right could
you see the greatness in Tom Brady at
Michigan or not necessarily absolutely
not he was a great college player but I
mean look they're saying he's the
greatest of all time now he's kid yeah
that's hard to see but but you thought
he had he was you thought it was really
a great player in college course you
know so as a quarterback the most
important thing as being the quarterback
of the United States his leadership
that's the most important thing he's
always had that Morgan epic so you had a
guy drew Henson right was his first
string right good memories you have a
good memory they're always testing my
memory
though it is a better memory that drunk
unless I don't want to remember certain
things which happens a lot too but you
had a quarterback drew Henson who was
actually the starter and he signed with
the Yankees because he wanted to play
baseball the problem is he couldn't hit
the curveball right couldn't hit a
major-league couple but he was a great
football player but he got hurt Tom
Brady took over the team became much
better right that's correct that's been
Tom Brady's thing right both truth and
it drew right they had drew in the and
the Patriots yeah our price this becomes
opportunity and that's exactly what
happened well let's say a lot of time
when you see them okay
yes it was a great guy so you're a big
strong guy ten years in the NFL what
position did you play
I put today you're a big guy for Titus
we're good catcher you could hold it
pretty because all your deep were you a
a blocker more or less or a receiver I
would tell you I was probably more of a
blocker well that's great and how big
are you have what are your six six
yeah just under six six right now right
now I'm about 250 to I had the
coronavirus diet but I played at about
you know 260 260 you look fantastic so
tell us so you're a big powerful guy in
this little bug knock the hell out of
you right yeah well mr. president if I
made from everybody at this table I
don't think the mind if I speak for them
we just want to applaud you and thank
you both for your efforts the past three
weeks it's been outstanding and we
certainly appreciate it I appreciate you
being here Morgan
the American people are watching this
and I'm finding it fascinating from
football players to state reps to all of
the things that you people do from a
rich couple that wants to go skiing say
you can ASSU the ski place don't bother
but you know no it's so fascinating to
see all different people different types
different jobs different everything all
different parts of the country so tell
us what happened one so you know I'm 44
like you mentioned ex-athlete still work
out you know as much as I can as hard as
I used to it would still work out and
shape it essentially I was driving with
my family and northern Michigan I have
three kids
Caden Bevan in case and a wife Michele
stop the only thing I can think of that
I did out of the ordinary because none
of them had thank God
never had symptoms still don't have
symptoms like working for them is I
touched a gasoline pump and that's
literally the only thing that I can
think of I don't exactly know how to be
completely Frank with you how are you at
it but the only thing because you must
go back and torture yourself with
lots of time I mean that when it's all
said and done I've had roughly 30 days
of quarantine you know that's 30 days
without being able to kiss your kids or
wife and you know do those things that
you normally do because right at at
basically at 12 days I went into the
hospital I spend another five days in
the hospital when I got out of the
hospital I asked the physician you know
can i how long is the quarantine lasts
and I think the safe and easy answer was
14 days right now I I'll tell you I went
to Creighton hospital to the hospital
Rochester Michigan they were fantastic
the physicians especially the nurses
like god bless the nurses and everything
they did my sister Diane is one of them
they were fantastic they were absolutely
fantastic and for a place where you know
the one thing I think we've all kind of
touched upon is look when you're in the
hospital when you're in that position
obviously it's lonely I don't know if
that sounds weak or what but you're by
yourself right it so when those nurses
would come in and see you and now out
not allowed right so when the nurses
come in and check your vitals every
three to four hours it's like alright I
got somebody to talk to
right so especially when you start to
feel better
very good guy gregarious I guess they
caught me he wants people he wants
people that's good go ahead yeah so you
know what through that process well
technically just on my backup if I made
just for a bit
so I got it and thought there's no way
okay I should check my temperature I
don't feel right but I thought to myself
there's no way my fact I made the joke
to my wife Michelle that I think I got
coronaviruses just totally kidding I
took my temperature is like 1 or 2 point
6 so I did like any guy or at least my
buddies would do I said I'll go watch a
movie and see if it kind of backs off
well it did it so I went through the
drive-through for screening and
basically I was sent home and said well
go for 8 for 14 days and see you know
you'll get through this your chances are
you probably had so the athlete in me I
will tell you this the athlete in me is
that's the tough guy that just pushes
right grinding and just getting things
done it kind of worked against me here
because truthfully if I could have
recognized hey stop trying to feed this
thing when it's only getting worse I
probably would have went to the hospital
sooner I do not and I was very aware of
that overwhelming hospitals but that my
points here for bringing that up is I
probably would have also gotten out of
the hospital much quicker so instead of
a 5 day stay possibly within a 2 or 3
days days specially if they would have
prescribed you know hdq that would be
the hydroxy I did and that made a big
difference I would say within 12 hours I
already saw improvement and when I went
into the hospital I was you know you
were pretty bad for a while yeah my
pulse ox was 86 you know so I did not
get put on a ventilator or something
like that certainly I was provided
oxygen support went on the z-pak the
zipper my scent and the and the zinc
zinc bayonet zinc as well yes yeah it's
all through the IV drip right so you're
just sitting there hanging out but that
period of driving too
the hospital my wife's driving me and
just seeing them her concern I mean
that's part of the right you see how
much they're conservative you know I'd
much rather me habit than her after her
kids she never got it she never got her
own kids with you next to you driving
together she never got yeah I want the
backseat littlest I be she's tougher
than you walked you ever think there's
no doubt that she's tougher right
there's no doubt about it
that's pretty amazing so the end result
is you think you're as good as new
right yeah probably about 95% the only
thing is my lung capacity isn't quite
where wise oh really yeah so if I went
for the dog I think I was starting to
work with your lungs correct it was
there yes I was once it gets too far
advanced stuff that's your highness of
pneumonia things showing up
darzee say what is it brown glass
appearance yes that's what comes in I
think you know yes what well that's what
I'm like hey first rent whatever you got
to prescribe let me get out of here
why didn't you take the hydroxy what did
you do that
television yeah I asked them about it at
night and I didn't know what was called
at the time I just hit the malaria jar
and they said okay and they ran through
some different thoughts about it and
they had they have beheaded it sure did
we've stocked up the hospice we've got
29 million doses yeah we stocked up a
lot of I think almost all of that I
suppose that's good see so somewhere and
you said you'll take anything great
absolutely so actually my business
partner Troy Evans
he's the one who was sent me a text and
said hey ask if he can get that yes so
you know between him and and dr. Lance
Benedict so I run some small businesses
you know having those and thanks to all
of them as well right so you know 46
employees and all that for in order to
do that in order for me to do that and
to be away you have to have good people
and thank goodness I did well I want to
thank you that's great that's really a
great story see somebody like you just
knocked not cold by the invisible enemy
right that was tougher than any football
player he ever played right
get some tough ones I know you did yeah
there were some battles that weren't so
good for me but I always kept fighting
yeah you did a great job great Jeff
anybody can be in the NFL for ten years
that's a big tribute that's not easy you
know how hard that is right yeah that's
right everybody always every year the
new ones come along and you just say
that ten years is a long time in the NFL
that's a great tribute to you that's a
fighter
I want to thank everybody this has been
incredible I thought this would be a
five minute meeting but I found each one
of your stories so interesting and
hopefully the media can play some of
these tears because they're they're just
just you know we're going through
something the likes of which I guess
we've never seen maybe you go back to
1917 1918 that was the big that was the
big plague that was a big one and
anywhere from Mike I guess 75 to 100
million people died but started here
started in a certain location that I
don't want to say because I love that
location so I'm not going to say but it
started in this country and actually got
brought to Europe and Europe is where it
did its you know thousands of people
died here large numbers but in Europe
tens of millions of people died so we
gave them no favor when whoever it is
went over to Europe right no favor but
not since then we have have we seen
anything like this and we're winning our
battle we're winning our war we're gonna
be doing announcing some very good
things in the near future the American
public's been great you know far greater
than anybody would have thought they had
minimum numbers of a hundred thousand
and I think we're gonna beat that
hundred thousand deaths can you believe
that that was a minimum and if we didn't
practice what we practiced and if they
if we did it a different way
because we had a maximum of 2.2 million
people who knows even if that's right
but the way I look at it if you cut it
in half and cut it in half again it's
five or six hundred thousand and that's
what we lost in the Civil War it's not
acceptable so we could
you know to bowl through as we call it
to bull through it just like treat it
like a flu if we did that so we made the
right moves now we have to get our
country open again you all know that but
this was great I thought so going to
Mike I said come on this will take five
minutes and it's taking a lot longer
than five minutes and that's because I
found it so interesting just great and a
really great Mike you have something to
say I just I just want to thank all of
these courageous Americans thank you for
being willing to be here and share your
story it is a tribute to your resilience
it's tribute to those health care
workers mark that you were talking about
that we're there for you and I just
president and I wanted to have a chance
to see all of you and let the country
hear your stories because while we
rightly as a nation reflect on the more
than 23,000 Americans who have succumbed
to the corona virus as a tribute to our
health care workers we also do well to
reflect on more than 44,000 Americans
who have fully recovered and you're
among them and so I want to thank you
for sharing your story it truly gives
hope to families that are looking on who
have a loved one who's struggling with
coronavirus today and I just want to
promise you that this president and this
vice president and our entire White
House coronavirus Task Force they're
going to continue to work every day to
have more stories like yours across this
nation and until we until we put the
coronavirus in the past and and
eventually someday have a vaccine that
ends this ends this once and for all I
think so and I think we'll make it a lot
of progress on vaccines were making a
lot of progress on maybe a cure meaning
a pill work because I think right now
I'd like to have that more than the
vaccine the vaccine takes a little
longer because they have to test it for
a period of a year or more so it's a
it's something we're going to come and
come with and and I really think we're
making therapeutically we're making
tremendous
I think tremendous progress tremendous
progress and we're going to see whether
or not mark whether or not what you did
and whether or not what Karen did
whether or not that that's a big part of
the answer but I think it's could be a
part of the answer let's see it's you
know it's one alternative but we're
gonna have numerous alternatives this is
another one just came you know the
Gilead drug REM disappear just came out
and it didn't come out it's a highly
sophisticated very very sophisticated
treatment that seems to show good
promise also well I want to thank you
all Jeff could I ask you a question
you're a great reporter and a nice man
look at you with that mask it's good you
look very good you actually much better
I think what do I know
am I allowed to take to take care and
over to see the White House doctor see
if we can help her out a little bit with
Lyme disease because Lyme disease is a
problem and there are some answers what
are you thinking you guys could have
report me for being a horrible human
being for doing something illegal that I
did something illegal help her out with
her Lyme disease do you think maybe
because I'd like to do that what do you
think should I do it I'd like to take
chances but I do so we'll take a chance
on it okay thank you very much we're
gonna have a news conference a little
bit later we'll announce the groups of
people that are going to be talking to
us we've made a lot of progress today
you see what's happening with our our
bump big bump in the road and big bump
is a lot less than a lot of people
thought it would be because of the
American people they've been incredible
so I just want to thank everybody we'll
have a news conference in a little while
we're going to announce the people that
we'll be talking to and I'm going to be
making a decision pretty quickly and
it's being done in conjunction with
governor's we have tremendous support
from governor's and what I do is going
to be done in conjunction with
governor's but we'll be doing that in a
little while especially in terms of the
people we have a lot of great people in
this kind
that know the different feels and you
know we have a lot of a lot of skill is
going to have to be used to get our
country back to where it was and we want
to do it quickly
whether it's restaurants or whether it's
airplane business or whether it's a lot
of other things we have a lot of
businesses and we have the best people
in every every profession including
medical and including political have a
political group to a lot of great
politicians so well some are great
somewhere it's so great but I put them
on anyway you know we want to have a
sampling of everybody so we have a lot
of talent I want to thank you all you
you folks are fantastic and just get
better get that your job finished up ok
get you there beyond represent you look
great and thank you very much you care
and you and your husband are going to
come with me and I'm gonna have you sent
over to the White House doctor they have
really great doctors they just wait for
me and ER they say they're there for me
but Mike do I think they're for you too
and if anything should happen you know
it's very interesting I was with
somebody not so long ago and he fainted
he had a bad something happened to him
and it was at a certain location and
within like a minute and a half there
were seven doctors standing over they
had oxygen I said I've never seen
anything like it so they are prepared
and they are great and we're gonna take
you over maybe we can find something for
you okay
well not get two of them yeah thank you
all very much we're seeing a little
while thank you
let's go reorganize areas you trap all
over your heart let the best oh my
goodness Paula let's go we're done